speaking of trans issues
here's someone trying to work out how to
feel about being misgendered I thought
this was kind of interesting
so I was just picking up my vehicle from
an oil change and the person came out of
the garage and said what can I do for
you young lady and I know that this was
intended to be a greeting of respect and
kindness or politeness maybe but I had
this immediate like okay young maybe
comparatively I'll take it but I was
like lady what do I do with that like
it's so complicated because I know this
person only intended kindness there was
a smile on their face like I knew that
they weren't trying to like patronize me
or gender me but I felt so gendered and
so inappropriately gendered and I don't
know what to do with that like what do
you do with that when someone like has
the best of intentions and I don't
really want to spend all of my spoons
trying to educate someone at the Costco
car center
what do you do with that uh what you do
with that is you live your life
um you move on and you live your life
and you leave Costco
and uh and that's it
that's what you do with that
these people they they are they are
they fall into this state of like
paralysis
after just
normal polite interactions they feel
like they have to analyze all of that
and in every every interaction that they
have every interaction they have with
anyone is loaded every interaction it's
a loaded interaction and uh nothing can
just there's no such thing in this in
the world of this kind of person
there's no such thing as just a polite
normal interaction you and I as normal
sane people we have those that that's
mostly interactions we have in Life or
just with like people acquaintances you
passable industry you say hello to
someone and that's it that's most of the
people you meet it's that's easy there's
no reason to even think about it
that doesn't exist for these people that
are
um
you know but that's also the consequence
of believing that you are the center of
the universe and everything that happens
is extremely significant and everyone
who talks to you has to talk to you a
certain way and approach you a certain
way and if they don't then it's this
traumatic moment in your life
this is the consequence that'll do it
for the show today as we move over to
the members block you become a member
and use code walls to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]